how come my name is Pierre bad
welcome back through the Attic well I
think it's not really back here at least
Shafter to IP the place everyone it was
really scary
since I'm obligated to play chapter 2
after the horrific experience Dedrick
faced in attempt to get his basement for
safety oh he goes to the basement when
he goes to the area he finds himself
confused
everything seems way back to what it
should be
he gets up off the floor and calms
himself down eventually the fires and
falls and blah blah Derek finds the
sounds and it's father's mic Taliban and
staff and gnats that spread the villages
now he has to go and save everyone in
the village from the monsters if they
don't find him first
I think chances are the masses will find
us but
oh well you got to do what you got to do
them right don't look everywhere and
scream hey we got a lantern no trace all
right come here Brandon
good all lanta always soon soon suit to
me we're all right we're in the basement
don't forget we got sandy pushin yeah
Jesus Christ come down pity pity stop
being drank all right G whoa whoa I'm
mr. Sharon I'm drew your dress
whoa you hallucinate all right Jase oh
wait let me use this anybody just stupid
sometimes
all right I feel a much better
hey I'm back why you seem like Freddie
all right let's just go
yes we're different me and if my
graphics ordered a game bad my house now
this is my basement these guys all right
Hey all the friggin doors are hot what
are you doing here get out of my house
I don't have anything right about here
this is not look good I don't like this
Hey
all right fine doing pretty well
targeting like a boss mmm I like a I
like that
mmm I like that this is not like
oh no now it back in the Attic oh no I
ain't just that oh yeah I'm there
however ever never ever I I just
oh my god miss yeah did you know about
this oh my god boxes in the closet this
is uh I can't trust anything anymore oh
my god ah I miss jack but it's alright
baby
let's just hug each other I know it's
like freaking man
oh my god alright let's scare the hill
having penis out of me
oh no we're back here okay ha ha what
about here say anyone I don't try away
my stuff wasting your land ability I'm
sorry you see that pot huh not a
mnemonic into that bathroom let me show
you again just haven't had the right
spin on it you gotta have the right spin
and then just go with it
hey I remember oh this is where the
Attic one started oh stop I just wanted
to shake out them the balcony or
something I don't know what something
broke someone's Vijaya oh [ __ ]
it's the intended way but I'm scared
we shouldn't be out in the forest bow oh
my god you follow me everywhere don't
you [ __ ] holy [ __ ] what was i boxing you
can't trust anyone these day Jesus guy
where is that coming from two miles I
can't walk two miles I'll guess I'll
hitchhiker helping I mean I might as
well don't think there's many cars out
here
Misawa I don't like a shiny fish I must
say this cousin story is excellent made
so far it has a lot of new elements that
I've never seen before
I am impressed alright it's loading a
lot though
and loading makes me mad there's my new
haircut it's a lot shorter
I don't like sure she was cutting me a
second man all right anyway we're in the
village I should probably stay on the
path in case those things are out there
good point Derek all right struttin and
town I like blood on the clown no we're
not gonna see I guess you can go in all
of these houses that's pretty cool why
do you want why don't I ever do to you
should I go here oh sorry buddy ahead
Brian Jesus Christ what happened here
Scotty
it does have me and my fans we were just
you know regular Friday night you know
you know oh all right
you know um the guy who lived here he
was a drug addict so you know I didn't
do that I swear it wasn't me finally my
lord of Santa's minion to cleanse his
village of the sinners thank you all
I don't know I don't think I would thank
for that I mean I wouldn't thank my it
was up top maybe because you can't
because I'll be alright all I won't have
it hand can't go here what about this I
can't go there okay I don't know I guess
we just investigated that dumb houses
hey fireplace Santa Claus Santa Claus
bow hey what do we got that's pity I am
NOT there is a father but stop judging
me
I am still your friend I was not talking
at the back all right I'm just I'm just
happy to see you in our I just pick up
that lion Adam got something else for me
Savannah in this pot nothing all right
sorry says you're not the real edition I
can't take you with me sir I just got I
need to remember which house has I've
been to take forever forever and ever
all right let's go here
Hey good cuz I'm wasting my okay we got
calls kind of weird placement for it
drawer but that's cool oh we got bad
shankar what is it - hey clock this is a
beautiful house beautiful house I would
be happy to call it my home alright
okay I don't know if I'm doing this
wrong like if I let me check the momento
maybe then no no I mementos of alibis so
dark pity I agree it is [ __ ] mark all
right let's check this out what's that
hello made the one with the blood yeah
let's check out the blood or something
there
oh no it's not that's my luck I can go
wait I don't know it's pretty cool I
never seen a bit I used let's go
bugger it's a lot of [ __ ] house
what do we got
okay maybe something underneath the bed
all right I must pass it out
monsters are killing everyone that face
bath get out of here go that but is it's
a construction area please step back
all right let's go here okay I can't
Hey look at what I found where I don't
even know what's going on let's go to
house [ __ ] action like snow to the house
get some ball I'm sad a fool waiting a
couple of gasps they were up to no good
started making trouble in my
neighborhood I got them only in the
fight my mom got scared she oh do you
know I wasn't for okay when when it
can't be in a bracelet register days and
oppression if they have no legs not
anything is god I'm sorry but I had to I
argued well aren't you a Brandenburg
hope is out there please don't be there
hello are we good
Jesus Christ fine let's keep on trolling
city hall vacation plans I'd be moving
boy oh no this is bad
he's lying who's a fountain
no it's but fountain we are friends
don't tell me you're lying to me it's
not the know you can never trust a
fountain of blood
never you cannot I really thought we
were friends
I am so disappointed let's check this
place out broken share too bad
anyone who needs to understand all we
have stashed a key in their battle house
at the end of the long path please go to
receive it if you wish all right sounds
like an adventure yes oh no oh why all
right
okay long long haul stuff I like the
background lot it's beautiful
all right I mean the moon look at the
moon I could just stare at the moon all
day long all right all right
hey okay the house with the long path
that's houses gone long bus passes there
we go this is not a long bad focus
there's so many how later and then of it
maybe you should stop talking to
yourself alright hey I can totally climb
that tree yeah yeah I'm [ __ ] out a
new tree okay okay long path houses
pathos houses long
[Music]
bells all right then I'm gonna hide that
you don't do that if I keep telling my
battles if you tell them it's very god I
[ __ ] kill ya
I hate ya I'm only here because I have
to I hate you
[Music]
Oh
rod mah gay okay go ahead
thank God their houses now we're in here
again
okay
this is crazy this is why all right
anyway I'm gonna in here bro hope you
enjoy this episode I like it in favorite
in all I can't stop you if you did
should absque right oh come on bro today
just created bottom abre and I'll see
you next time probably next video
because I recording one more after that
alright so cool hey console bro face
[Music]
oh you speak Japanese huh
I speak Japanese I invented the language
all right [ __ ] come here babe are you a
darling that's where you're wrong